ومعنا حول الموضوع في الاسود وزميل وديع
في عاني وديع اهلا بك
وديعه يعني كما تبعنا في ردود الفعل
التنافس ربما في من يصف بافضل لقب بلي
الاسطوره الخلود العظيمه الملك يعني هل
هناك مبالغه في هذه الالقاب ام هناك ما
يبرر كل هذه الالقاب هناك طبعا عوامل ربما
تبرر همم ما وصل اليه لاولا على ارض
الملعب كما راينا كان لاعبا استثنائيا كان
لاعبا همم بدا باكرا توجا باللقب العالم
الاول وكان في السابعه عشر من عمره فقط
وكان شيء استثنائي ساهم في التتويج
المنتخب البرازيلي تتويج الاول للمنتخب
البرازيلي عام 58 في مونديال السويد وكانت
مساله مهمه جدا لان حينما كان البرازيلي
يعتبر الافضل ولم يتمكن قبل ذلك من
التتويج باي لقب عالمي كان بلغ مثلا في
المركان عام 50 نهائي المونديال وخسر حين
شعب البرازيلي وحتى همم من يحب كره القدم
عبر العالم ينتظر هذا المنتخب البرازيلي
التتويج الاول في المونديال وحصل ذلك مع
بيليه مع شاب يبلغ اس 17 من عمره يسجل
هدفين في المباراه النهائيه اذا في مجال
58 توجد باللقب عام 62 وان لم يتمكن من
خوض المباريات الاخيره بفعل الاصابه ثم
هذا عام 1970 ربما في المونديال الاجمل في
تاريخ بطولات العالم ليقود تلك المباراه
الاستثنائيه على ملعب الاستيك في مكسيكو
والفوز على ايطاليا اربع واحد وهذا الهدف
همم الذي سجله قبل قليل هدف من بين اهداف
المنتخب البرازيلي واصبح اول همم شخص يفوز
بلقب العالمي ثلاث مرات ولكن اكثر من ذلك
هناك مهارات استثنائيه لم نراها من قبل
وربما وهو اخترع ابرز المهارات التي
رايناها فيما بعد مع من اراد ان يخلق شهد
نها ربما ابتكرها بيليه همم
بشكل ما عندما كان همم لاعبا توج بكل
الالقاب مع فريقه سانتوس كان رجل النادي
الواحد قبل ان ينتقل الولايات المتحده عام
سنوات هناك مهمه جدا هذه النقطه لانه لان
حينها كره القدم لم تكن موجوده في في
الولايات المتحده الفوتبول بالنسبه لهم هي
رياضه مختلفه كما نعلم بلي ذهب الى
المتحده كي ينشر هذه اللعبه هذه الرياضه
الاولى في همم بلد جديد كان يطمح لاكتشاف
هذه الرياضه وان نسال ربما من خلال حتى
ردود فعل ايضا مثلا اللاعب البرازيلي
نيمار قال انه همم اسمع صوت الفقراء
والسود وهنا نتحدث عن الفتره معينه في
السبعينيات والثمانيات الامور كانت مختلفه
جدا ما الذي سهل على بلاي ساهم في ان
يتمكن من تخطي الرياضه يصل الى السياسه
والتاثير في السياسه والتاثير ايضا في
المجتمع المدني والمجال الاجتماعي عموما
عندما
يلقب ايضا بالجوهره السوداء كانت نقطه
مهمه جدا بالنسبه لذلك المساله مساله
العنصريه طبعا تدخل دائما الرياضه ولكن
احيانا في الرياضه همم تختفي بعض شيء
عندما يكون هناك نجوم كبار كابلي كان محمد
علي لاعب همم اسطوره البوكس ايضا ولكن
عندما تخطى يعني عندما اعتزل كره القدم
عام 77 ودخل ما يدين عده همم كان وجود
بيليه مهم جدا وسهم في بعض التغييرات من
الناحيه السياسيه والاجتماعيه اصبح زفيرا
لليونيسكو سفيرا همم
ايضا همم عدد كبير من المنظمات الانسانيه
والمنظمات الرياضيه همم واصبح ايضا همم
يشارك او يمثل في افلام في افلام ترويجيه
ايضا واصبح وزيرا لاربعه اعوام في
البرازيل كان اول وزير همم بشرته سوداء
يصل ويشارك في الحكم في البرازيل في تلك
سنوات وكانت في التسعينيات وكانت نقطه
مهمه جدا بالنسبه لي همم
المجتمع البرازيلي وان كان فيما بعد كان
هناك ربما من يلوم بليه على انه لم يتخذ
دائما قرارات ولم يشارك في همم نضال
الاقليات في في البرازيل شكرا جزيلا لك
على هذه المعلومات زميل وديعه